the parents of a florida college student
who died in an alleged hazing incident
are pushing for a new federal
anti-hazing law
Florida State junior Andrew Coffey was
found unresponsive on a couch
the morning after a fika Phi pi Kappa
Phi fraternity party in November a
lawsuit claims he'd been asked to drink
an entire bottle of 101 proof bourbon
he died of acute alcohol poisoning nine
fraternity brothers pleaded not guilty
to hazing charges coffees parents spoke
publicly for the first time to our Tony
to copal in an interview you'll see only
on CBS this morning Tony good morning
good morning as you can imagine the
coffees are never really going to move
on from this but they are beginning to
move forward hazing has killed at least
one person a year since 1961 and Andrew
Coffey was one of four victims in 2017
in this new lawsuit the coffee family is
seeking justice and accountability their
goal to help lead a new movement against
hazing one that might keep their son's
memory alive by saving others my son and
if people in the past had gotten
together made me my son I'd still be
here if hazing wasn't a problem so we
have to yell as loud as we can in order
to get this stop I don't want another
family going through what we go through
cry ourselves to sleep it's been just
four months since Tom and Sandra Coffey
got the news their 20 year old son
Andrew had died in an alleged hazing
incident when you send your child away
he's the last thing you're thinking of
never even crosses your mind getting him
into his dorm getting his classes lined
up getting you know this never crossed
our mind I remember driving going this
doesn't happen to us Andrew had been a
high school athlete with dreams of
joining the Navy after college great kid
you can count on him you know he was she
hates my description of 53 6-2 swimmer's
body and handsome as the day is long and
a smile that'll light up a room
[Laughter]
just made the right decisions yeah
becoming a brother at pi Kappa Phi was a
goal even before he enrolled at Florida
State
his friends belonged and he joined with
them at some of the fraternity functions
and everything else and wanted to be
long what did you guys think about him
becoming a brother just told him we had
a deal
we just said greed suffered because of
partying or something like that then you
know you're out and he agreed to that
the idea of a fraternity sounds like a
good one right it does support system
brothers friendships for life but
according to a lawsuit filed by the
coffee's the fraternity had been hazing
and having pledges abuse alcohol for
years on the night of his death Andrew
drank a bottle of 101 proof bourbon in
an initiation ritual known as the family
bottle his lips they're purple
his body is extremely stiff and I can't
wake him up and I honestly I don't feel
as though it wasn't until the next
morning that a pledge called 9-1-1 why
do you think no one called for help
for so long that's the question that
wakes us up in the middle of the night
exactly there were estimated a hundred
people at that party and 99 of them
didn't help my son Andrew died in a
roomful of people that just didn't care
yeah and he died alone a spokesperson
for the fraternity says with the pending
litigation we are unable to provide
comment hazing is the byproduct of peer
pressure and peer pressure gets really
good young people to do things that they
would otherwise never do David Bianchi
is at coffees attorney helped pass a
Florida law in 2005 that made hazing a
felony and also blocks defendants from
claiming the victim went along willingly
the legislation named after a hazing
victim Chad Meredith is one of the
strictest in the nation this is what you
want to see except he wanted to say
United States of America that's too far
17 years after their son Chad's death
Jerry and Carol Meredith are still
fighting for stronger laws elsewhere you
know every morning I see his picture
I'll talk to him about it saying they're
still working on it so I pray there will
be people who will watch this interview
and they'll think to themselves
hazing has been happening for decades
sure what hope is there really that it's
ever gonna end well if we don't do
something it definitely is not going to
end you're just not supposed to bury
your kids they've joined with the
coffee's and more than a dozen other
surviving families to form push parents
United to stop hazing which includes the
Piazza family whose son Tim died at Penn
State last winter together they're
rallying for justice how do you break
the cycle accountability and education a
federal statute has to be written that
goes from the top you know where the
national fraternity is at risk as well
as the local chapter and then education
to high school students and if they
succeed their hope is that push never
adds a new member it's about legacy yeah
yeah if we keep his spirit alive then
he's not dead
if this can go to Washington DC it could
be the Andrew coffee law is that
something you'd like to see yes can't be
for nothing I mean no can't can't have
died for nothing
has to be purpose and there is purpose
shortly after Andrews death Florida
State University acted swiftly in
temporarily banning Greek life but FSU
president tells us there is still room
for improvement I don't want it to
happen again on our campus and I hope
other campuses are paying attention to
what we're doing because I think I think
we are making progress but I will say
this I think Greek life as we know it
today has to change has to change in
order for us to move forward with the
positive things that the Greek community
does the coffees and all the victims
families say it's important for schools
to step up and have stricter policies
across the board on this may be a
one-and-done rule yes that president is
so right it has to change and just
because it's been happening for decades
doesn't make it right I love whoever
said hazing is a byproduct of peer
pressure yeah that was lawyerly feel the
coffee's pain because you know when you
take your kids to school you're going to
Bed Bath & Beyond you're picking up
pillowcases and duvets they remember
reading the jaws a story back in
February never thinking would apply to
their life and then months later your
piece should be shown every college
student that's going away it really
should the parents would like that the
pictures of Andrew coffee so much
promise still yet ahead of him that's
what's makes them so much life I think
the message is that just like drunk
driving hazing is always risky and
always wrong that's what the parents
want people to take away from this